estado de Florida repite republicano
allí que dice Esto del voto
latinoamericano allí que análisis se
puede hacer es muy significativo para
América Latina lo que se decida en
Florida
Sí claro lo interesante de que he leído
sobre Florida es de los 10 latinos que
inscriben a votar 8 votan para
republicanos y lo que pronosticaron de
hoy en la noche es que my emitir que es
el candado que ganó Obama en 2008 y 2012
que iba a ir al a votar por los
republicanos aún veo el el
azul Entonces no ha pasado eso pero es
muy interesante que las zonas más
urbanas de de la Florida son las
demócratas y aún no no quedaron muy
satisfechos con las candidaturas que
presentaron habían aquí a freír Quiero
una una señora que presentó su
candidatura y la ganó el ex gobernador
Charly Quest Charly en su momento fue
muy muy popular pero ya es muy grande
entonces la la movimiento de las
demócratas fue muy difícil de encontrar
un candidato que fuera suficiente
popular con las zonas
urbanas donde viven los demócratas para
ganar el estado Entonces ya era como
dado que se iba a ganar no andes sí es
significativo Miami Dade todavía se
pinta de azul también
el condado de la ciudad de Orlando donde
también hay una población hispana
importante y también en tallahassi la
capital en el norte de la Florida
también se pinta de Azul Por el momento
Heidi continuó con usted también para
preguntarle otro importante hecho allí
en Florida también marco Rubio repetiría
allí para el senado también por los
republicanos también que análisis se
puede hacer era esperado no O era uno de
estos resultados que había expectativa
frente a lo que podría suceder
tiene muchísima popularidad es muy
influyente además en temas de
política exterior y él es miembro del
comité principalmente de relaciones de
exteriores y lleva una agenda bastante
conservadora antes de Cuba ante
cualquier cosa pinta lo que pasa también
mucho con los republicanos en Florida es
que pintan un nivel de bueno si eres
demócrata y eres socialista Y eso es un
fans news o sea eso sí es es no es
correcto no tenemos un partido
socialista Estados Unidos tenemos
102 partidos en Estados Unidos cada uno
de los estados tiene su propio partido
político Generalmente y generalizamos
dentro de nuestro murganos y demócratas
entre cada uno de los estados y luego
tenemos representación Nacional de ahí
somos una país de una democracia liberal
nuestra liberalidad significa elegir lo
que uno gusta con una economía abierta
no entonces pinta como si fuera un
demócrata una socialista y lo cual es no
es correcto de pintar ese ese rol pero
se juntan estos conceptos lo cual no es
correcto de la política norteamericana